what's happening now is that fire out or
under control it is out the police has
officially now said that the rescue
operations are over early this morning
the fire broke out and waters are very
congested area Adrienne now the police
is said that they rescued over 60 people
43 have died we were just talking to a
man and eyewitness he said that one of
his friends in the in that Factory was
rushed to the hospital was among the
injured but he's also passed it's a
rather sad scene hear people say that
many factories many small factories and
workshops operate out of this area but
also accused the builders of often
flouting safety norms later we'd be able
to show you how there are electricity
wires all entangled this factory they
were making plastic toys so people are
saying while the workers there died of
suffocation they were also living inside
that factory by the way but the load the
power load because there's everybody
also steals power from these wires and
tangled wires here that may have
exacerbated the situation and caused the
short-circuit which was possibly the
reason the fire occurred
in the first place now many of the
people here say that the workers come
from poorest states in India like butta
Pradesh and Bihar they get paid very
little to work here they have to sleep
inside the factories so there is also
that sort of exploitation that is
rampant here the police has barricaded
the flyover the police is barricaded a
very tiny Lane where that factory was
and the police is now saying that
officially there as few operations are
over how does your essential voilá
reporting live there from New Delhi
antral many thanks